okay so southwest airlines has now
released a statement and so we know many
of you have heard about recent
statements that may have been made on a
southwest flight we wanted you to hear
directly from us so they had they can't
even confirm by the way that this
happened so it will be hysterical if it
turns out this is all a figment of an ap
reporter's imagination i i will laugh
very hard
it wouldn't be rare the media do this
kind of stuff all the time media are
constantly reporting incidents that are
supposedly
damning of american right-wing culture
and then it turns out that it never
happened that kind of stuff does happen
but here's what southwest says quote the
southwest team takes pride in providing
a welcoming comfortable safe and
respectful environment for the millions
of customers who fly with us each year
southwest does not condone employees
sharing their personal political
opinions while on the job serving our
customers and one employee's individual
perspective should not be interpreted as
the viewpoint of southwest and it's
collected 54 000 employees southwest is
conducting an internal investigation
into the recently reported event and
will address the situation directly with
any employee involved while continuing
to remind all employees that public
expression of personal opinions while on
duty is unacceptable southwest does not
tolerate any behavior that encourages
divisiveness as it does not reflect the
southwest hospitality and inclusiveness
for which we are known and strive to
provide each day on every flight ah the
end of the world has arrived somebody
said let's go brandon on a flight ah
just just horrific just horrific okay so
southwest is apparently addressing it
internally
according to the washington post the
phrase has been used as a code by
conservative critics of the president
since the chan of f joe biden broke out
among a crowd at alabama's talita super
speedway in early october the story also
became a rallying cry for those
defending the pilot's reported remarks
with some saying it would in fact
encourage them to fly southwest first of
all that would be great
harvard professor and cnn analyst juliet
cayenne had a tweet okay so there are a
lot of tweets from a lot of blue check
mark people who are super upset
so for example expert on everything tom
nichols who writes books on expertise
because he's an expert on expertise he's
so experty that he doesn't know things
so he tweeted out
maybe for a flight attendant this would
have been okay but the pilot announcing
his political feelings with a slogan
like that strikes me as kind of loopy
if fa gets off the handle yeah but the
pilot
he knows he's risking getting fired i'm
not good with trusting a guy like that
with my life
so expert tom nichols
is now worried at what the guy's gonna
like fly the plane into a building
because he said let's go brand and these
people are insane i'm sorry they're just
crazy they're just crazy tristan snell
who is a person who i guess comments for
cnn that's literally the only reason
anyone has ever heard of him he tweeted
let's go brandon has become the maga
version of siege heil
oh has it i spot some differences i'm
spotting some differences like for
example i an orthodox jew not big with
the siege heil however let's go brandon
is hilarious
okay let's go brandon is great we'll get
some more on this in just one second
first you can't always control the noise
of the outside world but you can control
what plays in your ears with raycon
earbuds the new everyday earbuds offer
an improved rubber oil look and feel and
optimized gel tips for the perfect
in-ear fit raycons offer eight hours of
play time a 32-hour battery life there's
also a built-in mic you can take calls
at the press of a button raycon started
half the price of other premium audio
brands they sound just as good and
raycon's come with a 45-day happiness
guarantee so for example check these
babies out first of all they come in
this beautiful blue case then you open
them up and inside are the earbuds you
take them out you put them in your ears
behold the beautiful sound of raycon
right now my listeners can get fifteen
percent off their recon order at buy
recon dot com slash ben yt that is by
raycon dot com slash ben yt to say
fifteen percent on your recons buy
raycon.com ben yt and then we put these
back in their precious home
then you have asha rangapa who's another
cnn come i don't know what's in the
water over at cnn these people are
higher than their own supply asharangapa
she tweeted as an experiment i'd love
for a southwest pilot to say long live
isis before taking off my guess is one
the plane would be immediately grounded
two the pilot fired and three a
statement issued by the airline within a
matter of hours
long live isis
and let's go brandon again not the same
thing
like not the same thing i noticed
because
isis cuts the heads off people or puts
them in cages and sets them on fire or
you know bombs american service people
in afghanistan whereas let's go brandon
is a bunch of people who think it's
funny to say f joe biden because he's
the worst
then she followed up she couldn't let it
go and somebody tweeted back right
because supporting terrorists that have
run planes into buildings is atrocious
and not at all like saying let's go
brandon if you were former fbi it does
explain what's wrong with the fbi that
is a fair critique and she wrote isis
didn't run planes into buildings they
didn't exist in 2001. oh well owned
pawned mega did attack the capital
attempt to overthrow the government of
the united states and threaten to hang
the vice president so oh yeah so so
let's go brandon is the same as breaking
into the capital now you wonder why the
right thinks the left is loony and these
people cannot be let anywhere in your
power it's cuz of this kind of crap
where you suggest that if i don't like
joe biden because he's a bad president
that it's the equivalent of me rushing
into the capital and threatening to hang
my pens juliette kayem as i mentioned
before she tweeted if southwest air
doesn't do anything every passenger on
that flight has standing to file a
complaint with the faa and they should
do so southwest will then be compelled
to investigate or defend him have fun
with that no messing around in the air
brightline rule and somebody wrote back
not being flipped but a complaint for
what is he in violation of an faa rule
or regulation and she said yes pilot
conduct his words reflect the
possibility of anger management or
substance abuse it is worth asking
[Music]
so now if you say let's go brandon
publicly by the way i've worn a shirt
that says let's go brandon one of my
favorite shirts a great shirt available
from daily wire
if you if you say that now maybe you're
on drugs or drunk while flying
okay maybe you shouldn't get drunk
before tweeting juliet kayam
uh dino badaya tweeted southwest
airlines is now the pro january 6th
terrorist attack airlines
oh oh man again all these folks who
comment for cnn they are so crazy by the
way just a quick note here
it would be crazy right if i mean
totally nuts if it turned out
that pretty frequently these airlines
allow people to say political things
like say for example that american
airlines crew had been allowed to wear
black lives matter pins on their
uniforms last year
which is what they did
quote american airlines believes in
equity and inclusion for all
fundamentally we believe black lives
matter is an expression of equality not
a political statement it doesn't mean
other lives don't matter rather than in
our society black lives should be
mattered and be valued the same as
others also american has already allowed
employees to wear pins representing
recognized groups including religious
faith nationality military service and
lgbtq pride flight attendants can wear
three pieces of flair on their uniform
don't worry it's it's all this is the
rule for the left it's apolitical when
they say it but so political that maybe
you should get fired if you say it i
hope you enjoyed that clip from the ben
shapiro show if you did go ahead and hit
that subscribe button so you stay up to
date with all our future content